jobs at Mills like this help shape the
American Dream and created the modern
American middle class and in their
heyday Pittsburgh steel and Pittsburgh
steel workers were the envy of the world
today's groundbreaking is a sign that a
new heyday is coming for Pittsburgh and
for America one that will transform and
revive the American economy in every
corner of our great nation by bringing
together large scale academic research
and industrial development under one
roof mill 19 will become a true
differentiator for Pittsburgh and for
the region when complete it will be the
first manufacturing hub of its kind in
the nation in the world for that matter
researchers and practitioners at arm and
MFI are quietly reshaping what goes on
inside factories and warehouses the
technologies that emerge from this
building will have the power to make
things in a whole new way to trigger a
significant resurgence of major economic
sector in the United States and to
assert our global leadership in advanced
manufacturing
I believe that robotics is key to the
u.s. competitiveness in manufacturing
and one of the major factors in the
economic prosperity of the United States
through cooperation and coordination of
our industry partners and Carnegie
Mellon which is truly one of
Pennsylvania's greatest assets and a
global pillar of research and
development our investment will help
transform an entire sector of the
economy we are here today because
government federal state local
recognized the potential of this site of
the region and of these partners to
usher in a game-changing manufacturing
Renaissance this site is envisioned as a
place where people will thrive ideals
will be forged and this entire
ecological condition of the site will be
regenerated over time I would like to
acknowledge Pittsburgh's foundations
especially Richard King mellon
foundation the Heinz endowment and the
Claude Worthington Benedum foundation
they had a vision and a determination to
pursue it for more than 15 years in the
face of many challenges Carnegie Mellon
University owes an additional debt of
gratitude
- there are K mellon Foundation RK
Mellon gift to the University help
catalyze arm help launch our
manufacturing futures initiative and
help support our participation in this
facility today we celebrate not only the
future of manufacturing we celebrate the
rebirth of a great community a historic
community of Hazelwood and we understand
that what will happen in this building
just like it happened a hundred years
ago will forever change this world
you